audio is recording I'm recording audio
and video separately because I'm a
professional content creator hello
that's also how you can tell them
professional content creator oh we'll
just do a little bit of this whoa I
understand there's some empty space here
that's for your heart your empathy your
compassion or your vitriol I don't know
what kind of mood you're in today people
either watch because they're interested
or they hate something update video yeah
let's update I have sores on my mouth
now why because we've started poisoning
the cancer [__] I am a week and
a half out from doing my first
chemotherapy infusions day I don't even
know what the official term is chemo day
I did my first chemo day and I posted a
little video about that experience on my
Instagram and my Tick Tock hey wanna
come along with me on my first day of
chemotherapy I have a tick tock I know
I'm trying to do some tick tocks over
there they're very lazy but I enjoy them
I don't really have like a Content
strategy for how I'm rolling all this
out so spaghetti contents just get
thrown at all the platform walls stuff
sticking I don't know this one's
happening here for some reason it felt
like I should all these platforms are
like little plants in a garden you gotta
water them all YouTube you're just like
a cactus like you just don't die you get
so close to dying or maybe I'm the
cactus that doesn't die and you're just
the soil I don't know we're mixing
metaphors oh I started to take some
notes on some things I wanted to say and
then I got bored taking notes and I said
[__] it let's turn a camera on and just
start talking Chemo one week and a half
ago you can watch a video on my
Instagram or Tick Tock okay we've
covered that point this is what
professional content creation looks like
yes I've already mentioned that the
strategy for this content might seem all
over the place why because there's no
strategy for this content I am just
going with what feels right or good the
how and the wear of content
that's all over the place but for the
first time in a while like the why of
content is a little bit more clear to me
my why is because if there is someone
else out there that is sick and scared
hi me too that's why I'm making content
through this process and also it helps
me it really does help me process my
feelings and thoughts about what's been
going on because like a lot of stuff's
been going on you guys I got sores on my
mouth and I got dots all over my face on
my chest and my shoulders adding a
poison just like doing grape Vines all
throughout my body which will make you
crazy if you think about that too much
so we're not going to think about that
too much but just know that thought is a
gentle hum in the background of my brain
now
that there's just poison in my body
circulating all around doing all kinds
of wacky stuff with no warning really to
me I find out later when I'm crying
because my head hurts so yeah it's been
super fun so far maybe it connects with
someone else that's having a hard time
or feels very alone and scared and
they're also going through a sickness or
illness or even specifically breast
cancer and hey we're not alone you know
aliens are here now so how did chemo day
one go for me well chemo day one went
fantastic and then I got that Rush that
I guess happens after chemo day one
steroid Rush some of you warned me of
this steroid Rush the steroid Rush much
like the new Troye Sivan song Rush when
it was over I felt like I got thoroughly
uh the steroid Rush made me feel so good
and fine and like whoa Invincible I did
it it's not that bad maybe I'm super
human and maybe this won't be hard for
me at all it became hard because I am
average human oh hello it's day five
it's not going great it's all fine right
now it's fine other than my neck is
covered in spots it's been getting
really bad headaches and I've been
getting really uh pains and aches in my
body and my stomach hard to like um
figure out what to eat and to trust that
you're eating something okay we've been
going for crackers today it's like one
o'clock we're watching below deck in bed
and the hurricane came through we were
fine thank God because I was having
diarrhea in the middle of the night I'm
really hoping that our power wasn't
gonna go out in the middle of it Imodium
is our friend today crackers are our
friend today TV is our friend today bed
is our friend today and we're just gonna
hang out with those friends today shower
we might introduce shower into the mix
today but yeah today was a bit emotional
just because the there's like a
frustration in feeling sick not knowing
when it's gonna end and not knowing if
you're doing the right thing or so it's
just like swimming in uncertainty while
also just like feeling kind of shitty so
today's been bit of an emotional day I'm
glad that I don't have anything that I
have to do today other than
sit in this bed and wait out this storm
Where's My Water oh my God I have to
stay hydrated so I left my big girl
bottle in the kitchen like a [__]
idiot
oh God that was good where was I yes the
pains the horrors I also have this like
fun sort of like Amnesia when really
prominent things happen to me what they
like feel like right after so reflecting
on all of this it's I'm like how is it
so hard for me to remember it was so bad
for a couple days oh I think I just like
immediately started repressing it as
soon as it was done my brain just got in
there was like no we shoved this way
down way way down down down with the
years like 2016 and 2017. so for a few
days it was really rough but I also knew
that these wigs were gonna be some of
the crazier weeks I think it's just the
first time experiencing all of it and
the feeling of being in it and that can
feel a little claustrophobic of like
we're on this roller coaster and I can't
get off oh God okay I guess I just have
to be okay with this
and I am I'm okay with it
you know doing really good with this but
I really just let myself do absolutely
nothing which I think
hold on it's a lot of a lot of this all
day then finally I had a day where I
woke up feeling okay because I finally
gotten like a night of sleep praise be
to the goddess Ativan is this still
recording I think it is I got myself a
new little vlogging camera just a little
Sony Guy the one that everyone has with
a little toupee thing that's sitting on
top of it you know what I'm talking
about this guy you see look at that
little hair piece two of us might be
having a hairpiece soon there was no
vomiting thank God I cry when I vomit it
is so emotional I can diarrhea and do a
crossword I will cry when I vomit so
thankfully that didn't happen and
speaking of that what did happen not
speaking of vomiting speaking of being
thankful I started like developing and
cultivating this like gratitude practice
I know I say that because it sounds
stupid
and cliche and something a blonde white
girl would start cultivating but in the
moments that I felt really bad I tried
to think about like the little things
that felt good or the things that were
nice like my bed sheets were clean my
old ornery dog wasn't also sick or
needing super attention at the time that
I was I started into a 90 Day Fiance
before the 90 day series and there's
just so many hours of content there and
I'm like really grateful for that
everyone on that show is absolutely
insane is anyone watching it I am
watching it and it is fishing Bonkers
and I'm thankful for it um I believe
they're called glimmers now another pop
psychology term looking for the small
good moments throughout the day that
like light up your world and they all
add up to like a big
something I also realized that I was
just like eating super poorly and
because of the diarrhea like they send
you home where's my user's guide to
breast cancer look at this a manual for
how to do cancer they give this to you
the same way that like your refrigerator
and like your remote control comes with
like a little booklet on how to operate
it I have a booklet on how to operate me
during this time after having a bit of
diarrhea more at times than I wanted to
have the hurry up I consulted my booklet
and realized I was eating everything
wrong and I had to eat bland food I
couldn't just eat whatever I wanted this
is a bit of stream of Consciousness you
figured this out by now right
is all over the place and then I was
just waking up with absolutely
outrageous headaches which thankfully
I've never had to deal with before
there's the Gratitude part but I was
able to get some medication for that
which is great turns out with cancer
there's a medication for something bad
that you're feeling and with that I got
to do my first outing which was
appropriate for 37 year olds to Target
this is exciting I haven't driven myself
in a car in over a week we're going to
Tiny Target to get
headache medicine and we're gonna go get
that we're gonna get some chicken
so we can make some chicken noodle soup
and we might even be [__] crazy and
get a new kind of tea oh God the world
is our slimy sloppy oyster that was
really exciting because that was the
first time I actually trusted my body to
leave the house I really felt Tethered
to this place because the orifices in my
body were not proving that they could be
trusted guys I was in my car listening
to Imagine Dragons driving the five
minutes it takes to get to Target like
I'm on top of the world and it was like
this significant movie moment and really
really praying I didn't my pants just
based on the sheer excitement of walking
into a Target do you ever get the
Sensation that when you walk into a
store that you like that you're gonna
shoot your pants it's a thing this
happens to a lot of people for me it
does sometimes happen in Target I feel
like I have to pee right away I get so
excited Michael's craft store really
makes me have to urinate the
possibilities of potential projects 6
upon crossing the threshold of the
automatic doors just overwhelms me in
such a way that I have to piss truly in
hindsight I could have really done
something bad for myself but I didn't it
was a successful trip to Target so there
are a few days of real suck then there
have been a couple really good days
lately don't mind me I'm just
luxuriating in this gray robe that
someone suggested I get because the
mother and sister love these robes doing
their chemo and guess what I love this
robe during my chemo and guess what I
feel better today yes I have spots all
over my neck that need to be figured out
as a side effect and some more spots on
my face but
physically and emotionally I feel like
okay today and today's the first day
that I've woken up feeling like okay I
don't want to jinx anything so I'm just
gonna sit in this robe and enjoy it it's
5 12 p.m I'm in my evening wear
I made mashed potatoes I'm watching 90
Day Fiance I'm having a good day I
finally feel good today and it's showing
it's showing the new things that are
happening are skin related I believe
it's called chemo rash I've looked it up
I'm part of a Facebook group now about
her two positive triple positive breast
cancer lots of stuff going on in that
group I don't contribute I just lurk on
all of the posts very helpful I haven't
done anything on Facebook for 15 years
and now I just joined that group and
joining that I realized like yeah I have
something called chemo rash I got dots
and rashy kind of stuff all over my
shoulders and back and some on my face I
probably shouldn't be wearing makeup on
it but I felt good today and I wanted to
try to look cute for a second today and
it's my body not yours so
I'm falsifying an opinion that you have
not expressed to me I've been using some
cortisone on it I don't know what I'm
telling you this
between me and my doctor we're working
that out just some sores around my mouth
a little bit really dry nose and my nose
has been bleeding a little bit did you
want to know all my side effects as
these videos progress I'll develop some
sort of potential filter oh I've also
eaten
um cottage cheese I haven't had a
cottage cheese in a long time so that's
fun what else can I update you it's like
we're friends that were just like
catching up about only what I've been
doing you can tell me in the comments
what you've been up to that would be
nice to hear
[Laughter]
but today I'm feeling good
Let's Talk About Hair okay yeah we'll
talk about hair I've heard that two
weeks after your first chemo treatment
is when you start to see hair shedding
and hair loss I'm doing something called
cold capping during my chemo treatments
which means I put on a cold cap
specifically and freeze my follicles
essentially so that the chemo medication
does not get in there theoretically
results vary sixty percent of people
maintain their hair with the system that
I'm using and trying this upcoming week
will be a bit confronting on the hair
front and I've tried to let myself
really think through all of it all of
the good all of the bad all of the uh
all of the it's a little bit of a waste
of time thinking about it because you
can't really cross that bridge so we get
to it but I'm really nervous yeah
there's a chance I'll have to shave my
head which will be fine ultimately but
it'll be um a lot like I think I'm okay
with it though I really thought about
shaving my head my little brother Tim
God bless him is so great it's just like
a shave head looks cool wigs are great
like you can do whatever you want I've
already very Grace helvet if there's a
potential problem just buy a bunch of to
rectify it preemptively I've already
bought a bunch of headscarves lots of
scarves thought about wigs which would
be fun to experiment with other than
wearing wigs purposely kind of bad I've
never tried to wear one genuinely good
that will be interesting I'll be honest
I'm very nervous about this week but
it's not gonna kill me hopefully that's
why we're doing this whole thing so it's
gonna be okay there's like um man
there's like a lot of fear around this
whole experience because it's so
uncertain in so many ways and there's so
many variables but I also have this like
secret excitement about being challenged
in a way that I don't know I would have
ever challenged myself so I'm trying to
really connect with that feeling of like
there's a lot of opportunity for growth
when you get really uncomfortable and
I'm trying to really see things that way
and stay connected to that that part
kind of jazzes me up a little bit and
makes me more open to the experience of
losing my hair the fear and the anxiety
is still there but all of this
discomfort is temporary and ultimately
could lead emotionally to a place that I
don't know I could get myself to if I
were just trying to like do some
self-care you know unearthing a capacity
in myself stuff that didn't know existed
surprising myself I do think that the
emotional side impacts the physical side
we're trying to stay optimistic about
things even though we are not denying
the fact that this [__] sucks you know
it sucks but it's also manageable and
it's temporary and some of it is so
shitty it's hilarious I'm like that
strange kid in your middle school that
just always reapplied his chapstick
quietly okay so I think that might be it
for this little update I think I'm gonna
continue to do these throughout this
process because I do think it's
important to like communicate how this
is going throughout it because this
feels very lonely very easily and I'm
going through it too let's do it
together okay
okay
I need to
um go
smoke some dope and get some dinner
going goodbye goodbye for now goodbye
for now goodbye for now